Malkin is a Russian Savage wrestling his  thing but he has so much power in his  hands he is a Savage again he won the  belt by knocking homeboy out his right  hook and left hook are Savage he's only  six foot tall Russian though that's all  you need to know the gentleman that he  is fighting I don't care what  organization you want to compete in he  is gonna be a top five guy in any weight  class he is not only a middleweight  champion of the world in one  Championship he's also the light  heavyweight champion of the world nice  fight in the heavyweight champion of the  world this dude is a Savage RDR he's  giving everybody problems not only at  middleweight but also light heavyweight  he is a Savage he looks for the finish  this guy went to a draw with Andre gaval  in just jiu jitsu  Savage super Savage so I'm looking  forward to this man and that's this  weekend